alright guys what's up episode number 2
lunch money while Wall Street's trying
to get rich the rest of us just trying
to get a lunch money right special
co-host of the day miss Polina Mehra
Nova if I'm gonna record this and I'm
gonna sit here in quarantine she's gonna
have to do some work and she's gonna
join us
the first topic movie theaters what's
going on in the movie theaters movie
theaters brought in only five thousand
one hundred and seventy nine dollars for
the week of March 20th through the 26th
that's down 100 percent from two hundred
and four million is no more than the
same week a year ago so first of all
it's that down a hundred percent
obviously they round it up it's not 99
percent but it's pretty crazy two
hundred million dollars a year ago in
the same week this year did less than
six thousand fifteen 100 bucks is it
over like in the hoarder is why this is
news is they want to bail out like
literally we're at the point now where
our capitalistic society has turned into
so much socialism that the movie
theaters want to bail out Airlines want
to bail out everybody wants a bill well
they're not pandemic proof when's the
last time you went to a movie theater I
think it was with you three years ago no
we no we went one time oh yeah we we've
gone like no not at all so movie tears
they did 200 million last year so it's
not like it's a dying business but all
of a sudden people start to realize wait
a minute what if I could just watch this
at home
right but I think after all this is over
people are gonna want to go out are you
gonna go sit in a movie theater crowd
about with somebody who might have grown
of iris or might have other diseases or
germs no no right it's just I think it
okay it opened all of our eyes to the
fact that we did some pretty crazy stuff
used to pay 25 bucks in New York City to
go then you got to get popcorn you don't
get popcorn your night not really at the
movie theater and then you got to get
some candy and they go get a soda and by
the time you're done you spend a hundred
bucks for two people to go to the movie
you spend 100
normally people don't but you mean to
tell me that you wouldn't go pay to see
The Lion King 3d like you are so excited
to do that I did go do that yeah look I
think that movie theatres not going to
go away but it's probably going to be
more of like a specialty thing rather
than having one in every city things
like that but a 200 million dollar drop
to $6,000 $6,000 across the whole
country US domestic box office
absolutely nuts speaking of nuts let's
talk about the Marathon Man this is my
type of guy right here he's awesome so
he ran a full marathon on his 23 foot
balcony because his marathon was
canceled during the kovaydin lockdown
how old is this guy he is 32 he's so a
32 year old well he's obviously way more
athletic and obviously crazier than I am
but he's 32 he lives in the south of
France
right and he was supposed to run the
Barcelona marathon and because he got
canceled if he went on his balcony which
is how big 23 feet in his girlfriend
rightly so it was like what the hell
just do whatever you're gonna do but
like make sure you clean up the balcony
afterwards well my favorite part is that
how long did it take him it took him
like seven hours six seven hours all
right but he did it like this is why
this guy's a savage he did it in full
gear so he's got his hat on is that his
running sure dish you know the short
shorts gotta have short shorts running
shorts if you're gonna do something like
this but he's also got the calf warmers
on if you remember the calf warmers like
he's just got him on and he looks like
he's just the man but then then he
remember you're running on a 23-foot
balcony you run 26.2 miles for 6-7 hours
is this more of people going crazy or is
this how people get through the
quarantine I think that's how people get
through the quarantine and he said that
this was such a feat in like mental you
know training his brain to not let him
down imagine doing that we ran a
marathon in Greece last fact I made it I
did make it
2018 it was the hardest most ruderal
thing I've ever done I'm never doing
again I don't understand why people
would ever do it again but it's
definitely a mental challenge as well as
a physical one I can't imagine doing
that on the balcony
what should we do it here should we just
do it in the living room well mount you
pace on calls
all right so people are doing some crazy
stuff I joke today on Twitter and I said
that it's likely that our next
generation is gonna hate hearing back in
the quarantine kind of like your parents
used to say you know back in Vietnam or
I used to walk uphill both ways to get
to school that's gonna be our
generations like back in the quarantine
days in your kids will be like oh that
sounds so nice you don't have to go
anywhere you can just like chill at home
yeah maybe all right toilet paper bang
bang the toilet paper is missing on the
shelves of stores we've all seen the
viral videos people freaking the hell
out trying to get toilet paper
what's going on in a toilet paper world
so the toilet paper manufacturer
kimberly-clark is saying they're working
around the clock they're trying to like
you know get toilet paper on the shelves
but people are just grabbing too much
toilet paper and they can't keep up with
the demands my favorite part of this
story is that Kimberly Clark is not a
person it's a game of a company great
company name the company's Martin caps
like 40 billion dollars and they're one
of the largest producers of toilet paper
and they're literally like giving
interviews I think the president of
Kimberly Clark North America basically
said quote we're working around the
clock to help make these essential
products back on the shelves and quote
and what this reminds you is like
there's a lot of stuff going on right
now where businesses are either one
having to adapt to what's going on
meaning that there's logistical
challenges they've got to increase their
manufacturing but also we're seeing
other businesses that are basically
saying hey I was supposed to build the
stages for Coachella but instead now all
of a sudden I'm building basically like
FEMA tent cities right to help what's up
and start seeing like something as
simple as toilet paper where they're
literally there's an article in CNBC
where they're talking about how
important toilet paper is and the
logistical and the supply chain
and these people like what do they do
when it's over do they do the workers
say like man that was our Super Bowl we
got toilet paper back on the shelves and
they're not excited to go to work
anymore I don't know but I just want to
tell you guys there's literally this
brand launched a campaign called hashtag
share square people being so greedy what
does that mean what does that mean like
are you gonna share a square of toilet
paper the company is encouraging
Americans to give rolls of toilet paper
to those who actually need it yeah but
like then you're not sharing a square
you're sharing a roll yeah and it's we
were in the grocery store and we were at
the checkout counter and I just out of
the corner of my eye I spotted like in
the very back I thought it was rolls of
toilet paper a little I had to run I had
to get these kids out of my way I had to
grab one of the last things of toilet
paper because we weren't hoarding like
everybody else but then you realize if
you weren't hoarding now there's none
for you you beat up little kids to get
your paper I didn't know I lived with a
ninja here actually we're all we are
wearing all black are we the lunch money
uniform is black shirts all right every
time you come now you have to wear a
black shirt that matter if you like it
or not all right Justin Bieber this one
man this is going to the heartstrings of
American yeah JB man canceling the tour
the summer tour I actually don't mind
Justin Bieber at all I think that he's a
pretty good performer you know I went a
little crazy there for a while but made
his comeback this the reason why I
wanted to talk about this today is it
just goes to show that like even people
who you think are super wealthy who've
got you know millions and millions of
fans they're really being impacted by
this just as much as everybody else
I remember Zac Brown he had a fire like
90 plus percent of his his staff right
so you know big musician probably makes
hundreds of thousands of dollars per
show he had to fire most of his people
I'm sure other people in the event in
concert business or are going through
the same thing but he had how many hit a
bunch of them right he had like 20 shows
30 shows
anything to me as he canceled I mean it
45:45 dates it's started in May which
yeah that's a little you know early to
be doing tour but then September 26 is
the last one it was it like do you think
there was ever a conversation of like
maybe we can cancel half of it and then
like do the other half rows just like
cancel the whole thing
well I'm sure that they wanted to cancel
as little as they possibly could but
like what do you do what do you do
cancel the first couple then cancel more
then cancel more or do you just make the
decision like hey we're not gonna do
this right because you probably have to
also like get like on board a bunch of
employees you know kind of get ready for
but you know look if I'm Justin Bieber
you know what I do Bieber is a free idea
for you I don't need a royalty for it
but I hold a virtual concert and
literally just say hey here's the deal
you can only sign in in certain cities
so I'm holding a virtual concert from
New York City if you don't live in New
York City you can't come and you just
get people to pay for paper tickets to
watch them live and like go somewhere do
like a coronavirus concert interesting I
don't know would you take I would not be
for that no I can just find videos of
him singing online yeah but like you're
willing to pay for workouts that you
straighting explain what's going on in
the workout that there's massive
controversy going on in the workout
world it's just that a lot of
instructors are being laid off fitness
instructors so they are taking they're
using the zoom and taking their classes
online and you can pay in some cases
it's free but other cases you can pay to
attend the specific instructors class on
zoom and I don't like being at all
because I know I'm supporting her and
the money is going directly or her all
right that's fair it's really smarter
than to do it but like what's the
difference between the local what you
say what kind of class bar whatever that
is yeah bar but it's our two hours enemy
it's kind of really weird they spell
differently but what's there between
that instructor and Justin Bieber
nothing so there's entrepreneurs they're
trying to get their lunch money both of
them try to get their lunch money to get
his lunch money go for it but like I
think that he has plenty and my local
fitness instructor probably this is how
she makes a living but
I don't disagree but what do you think
Justin Bieber eats for lunch now I'm
just gonna be ridiculous what do you
think eats for lunch I feel like
something like cashews what all right I
really didn't Ozlem with a psychopath
speaking of small businesses we're in
New York City when you walk down the
street every single business is shut
down
it's like we're originally started 50% I
bet you it's eighty ninety percent of
businesses are shut down everyone's seen
the stats that most small businesses
have like two to three weeks of cash on
hand we're seeing massive unemployment
numbers in the millions already from
these businesses just not being able to
pay their employees we're even seeing
furloughs for companies they're being
bailed out like literally companies that
are getting bailed out are furloughing
employees because they can't pay for
them what's going on with Citigroup and
these small businesses so Citigroup it's
so funny that the CEO of Citigroup use
the exact same terminology that two
burly Clark used about the toilet paper
he said the bank is working around the
clock on an online portal for the new
three hundred forty nine billion dollar
small business relief program so
Citigroup is gonna basically try to hold
people on board to it much faster yeah
and these are for the small business
loans that will be forgiven you know if
you keep your people on payroll yeah
it's super confusing if you go look at
the stimulus package unless you're an
expert at reading it or you're a nerd
you're gonna have a hard time figuring
out what's going on there so Citigroup
obviously is trying to build this
website to help people figure it out if
you want on Twitter go follow at
permanent equity a buddy of mine
Brent B Shore and his team they've been
doing a fantastic job of basically
taking the professional language and
kind of translating it into you know
everyday kind of nomenclature
essentially people who are watching
lunch money it's much easier to
understand tells you what to do and how
you can maybe save some money get some
of these loans etc but to finish up the
show like what do you think is gonna
happen to the small businesses how what
percentage of small businesses that have
been mandated to shut down or have shut
down will come back over under 50% I
want to see
that even if it is for a short period of
time I think why so for the profile I
talked to several small business owners
about how they're dealing with the whole
like shutdown situation and they are
saying like literally I went from X
amount of revenue to zero in one
overnight um and they say that they can
keep this going for maybe a few weeks
maybe a month or two but like when your
rent is $25,000 how are you supposed to
keep paying rent in your existing
expenses with no revenue so I don't know
I really hope I mean what doesn't you
exceed you're gonna look like without
small business well I just they're gonna
try to get replaced by other small
businesses right other people will step
in towards the recovery but it also I
think brings a question like one of the
things that a lot of businesses
previously talked about the
entrepreneurs etc was like hey I have a
recession-proof business like I know you
talked to the Barbie Tom bought the
barber yes I talked to a barber in New
York City like a hair barber you know
like cut hair like me barber shop the
reason he's wearing a hat says cuz his
hair's getting really long and like
Shavian looking like Einstein over here
without the intelligence so the
barbershop and he said that when he went
to barber school his dad said well at
least you picked a profession that's
recession-proof and he said he was
thinking about that quote just now and
he said last year he thought him and his
friends were sitting around there like
what would it take for the barber
business to go out of the barber shops
to go out of business like what could
have happened for that to occur and he
said it never in a million years that I
think it would be a global epidemic
yeah the virus is spreading yes I've
been warning people just saying man just
saying all right guys remember lunch
money show every day noon ish we're not
we're actually recording this afternoon
because we don't got our [ __ ] together
it could be before noon afternoon right
at noon or at 5:00 o'clock while Wall
Street's trying to get rich the rest of
us trying to get her lunch money right
and thank you too miss Polina for
spending the time she actually
researched he did more work than I
normally do she like wrote some stuff
down put some links together I read none
of them just came bullshitted
hopefully we will do this again tomorrow
leave a comment subscribe share the link
basically do all the things to help us
grow this but I'm having fun doing it
sounded like people liked the first
episode and hopefully we can get more
and more people should I bring my lunch
box for the next finish butter
alright guys that means we will see you
tomorrow